now you're the general manager I'm the
general manager I'm how do we be working
in hotels but hotels would be nine weeks
they said I'd never been in a hotel but
I've always been in restaurants
full-service restaurants how does a
restaurant manager become qualified to
be a general manager of a hotel when
you've never worked in a hotel before
it's not that complicated take care of
the guests check all that complicated I
don't believe it is I can do the work
it's not that hard there's only like six
seven things I need to learn well all
the major problems okay problems cally
is the owner
she's the major pro a major problem she
is too controlling and my hands are
meantime if you're not being allowed to
do the job you came in to do why are you
here I'm here because I'm emotionally
invested in the place investing weeks
well my wife's been here all these years
anytime somebody calls in sick the first
person I call is Mitzi we've always
thought it's a gold mine we just can't
figure out why we can't get people in
the seats going away from Masson to be
successful is for Cali to back out while
these things have the vinyl we're
disgusting if I could take this off join
in say looks better all right do not
need to be a general manager to make
that decision do you know is there a
server or I will bring sober up replaced
and his or her name Mitzi Mitzi as your
wife yes how are you good how are you
that's all the first shall we okay and
then we'll have a chat all right what
would you like
well in New Mexico are we yes we are in
my leathers taste of Tuscany yes why
would you just go for a Mon stunning
delicious Mexican cuisine I guess it's
because she thinks there's enough of
them it's crazy the prosthetic looks
good again the chicken piccata uh sounds
interesting okay
the lamb lollipops yeah it's not cheap
is it $23 with a Mali pops thank you I
go ahead let see how
I know good food thank you so much
our food is really good to be forewarned
it's not the cash cow all over my plate
we shed normally goes with tomatoes yes
this is olives in anchovies popular dish
it's like vomit are you saying o day
idea word got out that I'm in town and
the restaurant is starting to fill up
with customers I feel sorry for all of
them
Wow there we go my $22 lollipops vanilla
mousse member staff here what do you
think's wrong with this place I think
Keller's reputation is it that bad
she's rude she's rude mm-hmm she's brass
she's short
she's not flexible I think you get the
picture oh thank you my god
blimey not what I'd call a loyal
workforce fat $23 dreadful toughest
tonight lamb I love lamb stuff as heavy
blue top and perhaps a little rare a
little tough what is going on no you
haven't got much hotel experience but
isn't this your forte prescience yes
bloody hell I'm finished with that thank
you I mean dreadful absolutely tell him
it's that lamb frozen the lamb comes
frozen and we thought boss you find out
where it's from
yes lamb lollipops no go so far nothing
of taste it has even a remote connection
to the area nothing local nothing
authentic nothing New Mexico New Zealand
New Zealand lamb that carts right that
parts right our chicken is piccata is
nontraditional thank you for visiting us
here but son de Mesilla my name is
Callie I'm gonna do just a little music
for you this afternoon
little ROK number from Cher
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how are we boys in the kitchen I'm not
too sure what's more scary the food or
singing what would you say bunch of
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and thanks for joining us here yes
that's not about me no she is not share
I am sorry
it's probably why about this place